Let's now talk about the second part of this lesson called PID control.
PID control is a vast field in control, and many, many classes can be taught about this one subject matter.
What I'll do is I'll give you the very basics, and I'll let you implement the very basics.
I promise it'll be fun.
You'll be able to drive a car around, and the Google car to the present day uses a version
of this exact same controller that is, of course, much more tuned the specifics of our car.
But you get to see some of the essence of what it means to control a car.
Here is the problem. Consider the following car with a steerable front axle and 2 non-steerable wheels in the back.
Say we wished this car to drive along this line, which is the output of our smoother we just discussed.
Let's assume the car has a fixed forward velocity,
but you have the ability to set the steering angle of the car. How would you do this?
You would keep the steering constant?
You would use random steering commands?
Or you could set the steering angle in proportion to what's known as the "crosstrack error,"
which is the lateral distance between the vehicle and the so-called reference trajectory.
The third possibility is steer in proportion to the this crosstrack error or CTE.
Choose one of those that you think is best suited to control the car.